لماذا يبقى منزلك على قيد الحياة ، المضي قدمًا ، إنه
عمل كثير نحن نولي اهتمامًا كبيرًا
لكل التفاصيل من الألف إلى الياء في كل
نقطة من الدعامات إلى السقف
وكل شيء بينهما عندما
يحين الوقت لاتخاذ قرار بشأن أي
مستوى  من المواد أو ما يجب استخدامه ،
لم ننتبه إلى الكود ، لقد ذهبنا
إلى ما هو أبعد من الكود
وحاولنا ذلك وسألنا السؤال عما
يمكن أن يبقى على قيد الحياة الأكبر
وحاولنا باستمرار أن نبنيها لذلك
وكان هذا  أخذ المهندسون جميع أنواع
الأشياء التي تعرفها على
ما يبدو ، لذا فهمي هو
الكود ، فإن رمز علامة أندرو في
فلوريدا بانهاندل هو أنه عليك
بناء منزل لتحمل 120 ميلًا في
الساعة للرياح التي قمت ببنائها لتحمل
240 ميلًا في الساعة للرياح  حق
240250 شيء من هذا القبيل أنه يتم
سكب الجدران الخرسانية فوق أعمدة 40 قدمًا
وحديد التسليح ، كل الكابلات الفولاذية في الجدران
تذهب من العوارض فوق
الأعمدة من خلال السقف و ER
وتستمر عبر السقف أسفل
الجانب الآخر على الحائط الخلفي